the NCAA is opening an investigation
into how Michigan State handled sexual
abuse allegations against former US
Olympic dr. Larry Nasser Nasser was
employed by the University and USA
Gymnastics when he abused young women
and girls the NCAA will look into
potential violations of rules at MSU
related to those assaults more than 150
victims have given impact statements in
court since last week and NASA is
expected to be sentenced later today dr.
Jon LaPook has been following the story
and joins us at the table John good
morning good morning Gail Michigan State
University students will protest Friday
to demand president Lou Anna Simon
resign over the scandal but a member of
the school's Board says Simon will not
step down many of NASA's victims
yesterday accused Michigan State
University and USA Gymnastics of
allowing abuse to last for years your
priority should have been my health yet
your priority was solely to molest me as
former US national champion gymnast
Matty Larsson addressed Larry Nasser in
court Tuesday her emotions ranged from
sadness to rage I can't even put into
words how much I hate you Larson says
she once purposely injured herself at
home to avoid going to a training camp
where she was treated by Nasser since
last week more than a hundred and fifty
women and girls have confronted Nasser
in court but none quite like Emily
Morales demanded an apology I want you
to apologize to me right here I want to
forgive you but I also want to hear you
tell me that you forgot Nasser appeared
to respond saying he's sorry u.s. AG and
MSU how could you have let this happen
many victims also directed blame at USA
Gymnastics and Michigan State the first
step towards being able to change is to
be able to acknowledge what you did
wrong and us AGMs you have consistently
refused to do that in November
CBS News sat down with Rachel den
Hollander after Nasser pleaded guilty to
sexually assaulting her and six other
girls
then Hollander is expected to be the
last victim to give an impact statement
in court after being the first victim to
publicly reveal her identity I can stop
my abuser but I can't do anything about
the person that rises to take his place
if the culture of abuse at these
organisations isn't changed with three
victims including den Hollander left to
give their impact statements today the
judge says sentencing is likely to
happen later this morning nasa was
sentenced to 60 years in prison last
year for child pornography charges in
this case the prosecutor has asked for
up to a hundred and twenty five years
John that judge to judge aqua lena who
said to the girls leave your pain here
and go out and do your magnificent
things thank you for continuing to
report on this thank you